ya hemos visto que se pueden clasificar
los triángulos como equilátero isósceles
o escaleno basándonos en la longitud de
sus lados sin ninguno de los lados son
congruentes el triángulo se conoce como
escaleno en este triángulo estoy
suponiendo que estos dos lados no son
iguales y ninguno de estos dos es igual
a éste así es que este es escaleno
estamos haciendo un breve repaso ahora
si dos de los lados son iguales si dos
de los lados son iguales
el triángulo se conoce como isósceles
voy a marcar que estos dos lados son
iguales así es que este triángulo se
conoce como isósceles triángulo
isósceles y si los tres lados son
congruentes si los tres lados son
congruentes si estos tres lados tienen
la misma longitud
el triángulo se conoce como equilátero
triángulo equilátero y hay quienes
consideran que éste también es un
triángulo isósceles suponiendo que un
triángulo isósceles es aquel que tiene
dos lados iguales así es que este
triángulo de aquí es
a la vez equilátero isósceles mientras
que este de aquí es un triángulo
isósceles no equilátero pero como hemos
dicho esto es tan solo un repaso lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es mostrarte
como si no conocemos los lados del
triángulo tan solo algunos de sus
ángulos como podemos determinar qué tipo
de triángulo es por ejemplo si nos dan
este triángulo si nos dan este triángulo
y nos dan dos de sus ángulos digamos que
este ángulo de aquí es de 40 grados
pongamos que este ángulo es de 40 grados
y este de aquí es un ángulo de 50 grados
basado en esto como podrías clasificar
este triángulo como escaleno isósceles o
equilátero la clave aquí es que si
conoces dos de los ángulos internos de
un triángulo puedes conocer el tercer
ángulo pues ya sabemos que la suma de
los ángulos internos de un triángulo es
de 180 grados por lo que este ángulo
mide 40 grados este mide 50 grados su
suma es 90 grados con lo cual 180 menos
90 grados nos da que éste
mide 90 grados de hecho podemos indicar
que este es un ángulo recto así es que
si tenemos un triángulo donde todos los
ángulos internos son diferentes eso
quiere decir que todos los lados del
triángulo son diferentes una manera de
ver esto es si este ángulo de aquí se
hace más grande deje de ponerlo con un
color adecuado para indicarlo si este
ángulo de aquí se hace más grande
entonces este lado se va a ser más
grande si este ángulo se hace más grande
o más pequeño entonces este lado se hace
más grande o más pequeño y si este
ángulo se hace más grande o más pequeño
entonces este lado se va a ser más
grande más pequeño con lo cual podemos
ver que si tenemos tres ángulos
distintos vamos a tener tres lados
diferentes así es que basados únicamente
en los ángulos internos de este
triángulo los cuales son los tres
distintos podemos afirmar que este es un
triángulo escaleno ahora veamos un par
de ejemplos más supongamos que ahora
tenemos un triángulo
del cual conocemos este es un triángulo
del cual conocemos a ver hagamos algo
interesante aquí supongamos que
conocemos no sé que este ángulo este
ángulo es de 70 grados que este es un
ángulo de 70 grados y que este ángulo de
aquí es un ángulo de 40 grados
así es que basándote en información que
te estoy dando qué tipo de triángulo
podría ser este bien como hemos dicho ya
sabemos que los ángulos internos de un
triángulo deben de sumar 180 grados y
aquí tenemos un ángulo de 70 y un ángulo
de 40 que suman 110 grados así es que
110 grados más que ángulo nos da 180
grados por lo que el ángulo debe medir
70 grados así es que este ángulo de aquí
mide 70 grados estamos en una situación
donde dos ángulos son iguales así es que
este ángulo va a determinar la longitud
de este lado opuesto entre mayor es el
ángulo mayor es el lado y viceversa así
es que ese ángulo determina este lado
mientras que este ángulo de aquí
dependiendo qué tan grande o qué tan
pequeño es va a determinar
longitud de este lado por lo que debido
a que estos dos ángulos son congruentes
tienen la misma magnitud sus lados
opuestos van a ser también congruentes
es decir este es igual a éste así es que
basándonos en la información que tenía
en un principio pudimos demostrar que
dos de los ángulos eran iguales por lo
que podemos concluir que este es un
triángulo isósceles y sólo se les voy a
hacer otro ejemplo y ya te puedes
imaginar qué es lo que voy a hacer en
este tercer ejemplo aquí tenemos un
triángulo y vamos a establecer que este
ángulo mide 60 grados este ángulo
también mide 60 grados qué tipo de
triángulo es este si este ángulo mide 60
grados y este de aquí también mide 60
grados para que entre todos sumen 180
grados esté acá también tiene que medir
60 grados y si tenemos que todos los
ángulos son congruentes eso significa
que también todos los lados son
congruentes por lo cual tenemos un
triángulo equilátero y como hemos
mencionado este triángulo también lo
puedes ver como un triángulo isósceles
pues tienes por lo menos dos ángulos y
dos lados congruentes aunque en este
caso que los tres ángulos son
es un triángulo equilátero